France Italy and Belgium have just
obtained three more months to present a
detailed calendar of budget reforms
Commissioner Pierre Moscovici outlined
the Commission's new approach to any PS
we met two of them ELISA Ferreira from
socialists and Democrats and esta de
lana from the European People's Party to
speak by the situation in the eurozone
so have the stability pact rules being
respected it's a matter of credibility
and Trust in the European Union and in
the European Commission and the answer
that was asked to the Commissioner about
on the on the basis of what legal
grounds have you given this extra time
no real clear answer was given to that
question so for me the question mark
remains and that's another good thing we
need clarity here very quick this is
exactly the interpretation of the rules
we have got to use to the fool the
margin of maneuver that is allowed
because we are in a serious economic
downturn and in exceptional
circumstances so it is an obligation of
commission to use the flexibility that
is embodied in the legal texts to use it
in these circumstances so what room for
manoeuvre should national governments
have in relaunching economic growth our
economy hasn't recovered yet so we need
to stick to the rules that we agree to
while at the same time and the younger
Commission is doing this seeing how we
can stimulate investments but not public
money money that is actually coming from
the private sector can we stay for
longer in this stagnant economic
situation prices are falling down there
is no recipe for this so these calls for
an emergency action friendly decide the
fiscal policy so old member states
should be told by the Commission to say
okay you start investing you start
slowing down the adjustment process as
foreseen in the legal texts should
Germany be putting in greater investment
as he use leading economy Germany is a
major player we don't need to repeat it
but it cannot play its power only in the
benefit of its own citizens because they
also German
citizens have benefited and benefit from
the stability of single currency for
from the internal market an open market
and when there is a crisis we have got
to look at the whole of the Union and
not to the internal affairs I don't
think it's a good thing to focus the
debate only on the German investment
question if that means that other member
states are not implementing the
structural reforms that they have to do
it should be a balance and every member
state should play its role and what I
see in this debate too often is that
there is a focus on one or there's a
focus of two to let maybe others of the
hook and that's not my way of doing
politics all member states have to be on
board next year we'll see a review of
the two pack and six pack what would you
like to see change maybe we should take
a bit more time to have a thorough
review of the six and the two pack and
that is what we're going to do to come
the next couple of months one of the
three elements that I can already
confirm of what we will be looking at is
of course this democratic legitimacy or
the ownership and the transparency of
how decisions are taken that will be a
key part of the report you cannot go on
adjusting public investment and
expenditure private investment and
expenditure and doing this in old member
states at the same time then you end up
without any source and oxygen for the
economy